PROFESSOR: So another important
source of convection in an air
filled room is buoyancy
due to differences
in the density of the air
as the temperature varies.
Even relatively small
variations in temperature
can lead to significant flows.
There's another
dimensionless number,
which controls the
appearance and strength
of such flows, which is the
Rayleigh number, written Ra.
And this is also a
physical property
of the-- it's a combination
of physical properties
of the fluid plus the geometry.
So in this case, the
relevant geometrical scale
is the height, because this is
a gravitational instability.
So in the Rayleigh
number, we have gravity.
I'll just define all these--
a gravitational acceleration,
which is 9.8 meters
per second squared.
We have-- well, if we define
the change in air density
relative to the initial
air density that's
caused by changes
in temperature,
if the temperature
changes aren't too big,
there is a linear
response, which
is defined by the thermal
expansion coefficient beta, so
beta delta T.
So beta is the thermal
expansion coefficient.
And this, for air, is
something like 3.1 times 10
to the minus 3 inverse Kelvins.
OK, so basically we have gravity
times the change in density.
That's the buoyancy
force per volume.
And so we can write that as
beta delta T. Or I should say,
delta T is T maximum
minus T minimum.
So there's some
temperature change.
So the example we're
going to consider
is a cold plate above a hot
plate with a fluid in between.
And then we have also
some other parameters.
So we have-- the length
comes in cubed now.
So it's very sensitive to
the size of the system.
And then we also have
the kinetic viscosity
of air, which I'll
write again here.
This also appeared in
the Reynolds number.
And for air, this is 1.5
times 10 to the minus 5 meters
squared per second, roughly.
And then finally, we
have alpha T, which
is the thermal diffusivity.
So this parameter gives a sense
of how quickly heat energy is
transmitted by conduction and
diffusion through the fluid.
And thermal
diffusivity, turns out,
is pretty close to the kinematic
viscosity for a gas, like air.
And the reason is that
the ratio of thermal--
well, in other words, the ratio
of the kinematic viscosity
to the thermal diffusivity
for air is around 0.7.
And this ratio, by the
way, is called Pr--
the Prandtl number--
which is also
very important in
these sorts of flows.
And for gases, basically
kinematic viscosity
refers to the diffusion
and momentum in the air,
whereas the thermal
diffusivity alpha is
the diffusion of heat energy.
And in a gas, both
those processes
occur by collisions
of molecules.
And since it's the
same mechanism,
you have roughly the
same order of magnitude
of those quantities.
So basically, all
these quantities
enter the Rayleigh number.
And the way to think
about, qualitatively,
what the Rayleigh
number is telling us
is the ratio of buoyancy
force to viscous stress, which
is trying to fight that
motion as we talked
about before, but also heat
diffusion or thermal diffusion,
which is also kind
of fighting it,
because it spreads
out the temperature
gradient because this is
a motion that is naturally
driven whenever a temperature
gradient exists which
is unstable.
So because this beta
is typically positive--
so when you heat the
fluid, it expands.
That's certainly the
case for most gases
and even for many liquids.
Then what I've sketched here is
an unstable density gradient,
where if the cold
is above the hot,
there's a heavy fluid
above a light fluid.
And at conditions of
low Rayleigh number,
this is stable.
And in particular, if
the Rayleigh number
is less-- for this
particular case of two fixed
plates and an infinite
layer of fluid,
if the Rayleigh number
is less than 1708,
then we have a stable situation.
Or it can be at
least meta-stable.
It won't go spontaneously
unstable, so at least local--
stable to small perturbations.
But then at this critical
Rayleigh number of 1708,
we start to get some spontaneous
flows, because what's happening
is that the heavy
fluid above, which
I've sketched in blue--
the cold fluid-- it wants
to sink to the bottom,
whereas the red, warmer
fluid is lighter and
wants to rise to the top.
And so it has to find
a way to do that.
And eventually, it
breaks symmetry and just
starts forming convection.
And that is so-called
natural convection.
So you have plumes of hot fluid
rising and cold fluid sinking,
driven at first by
fairly regular arrays.
But as you increase the
Rayleigh number even further,
and if you increase it a
lot, then you eventually
get to a complicated
turbulent flow.
So if you increase the Rayleigh
number on the order of 10
to the 4, you may have
some unsteady situations
as we saw with the
vortex shedding.
But here, if you go to a
very high Reynolds number--
Rayleigh number, I should say--
greater than about 10 to the 9,
then you again get turbulence.
So simply these temperature
variations are strong enough--
those buoyancy forces--
to completely destabilize
the fluid and generate
a turbulent mixture
where the hot and cold
are very quickly mixing.
And I've sketched
here the hot and cold
as still being separate.
But in fact, due to diffusion,
they will kind of also
be re-equilibrating
all the time as well,
although the temperature
gradient is needed
to kind of maintain that flow.
So let's see how big
the Rayleigh number
is in different situations of
interest for indoor air now,
as well.
So if we look, let's
say, in a room--
so let's have-- this
is another room.
And let's imagine again, we have
our heating and ventilation air
conditioning.
Let's say, it's an
air conditioning unit
on the top, which is
dumping in some cold air.
And it's giving
it some velocity.
So the velocity is associated
with the Reynolds number.
That inertia will lead to
destabilization and vortices
and mixing by itself.
But let's see what the effect is
of the temperature difference,
OK?
So we're injecting cold air.
And we usually put it on
top, because we actually
want good mixing in the room.
That's how these
systems are designed.
We also inject heat normally
from below, for example,
from the lower sections of
the wall or from the floor.
And so if we were-- and in
fact, I could just mention,
if we were to heat,
we would do that.
And if we're doing air
conditioning or cooling,
we would do it from above.
And so basically, there is an
unstable gradient like this.
And let's actually put
some numbers in here.
So what if we say that
the temperature difference
between the fluid we're
injecting, whether it's
heating or cooling, relative
to the sort of background
air in the room, which
is, let's say, closer
to the target temperature--
is approaching target
temperature-- let's say,
it's only 10 degrees
C. So that seems
like not a very big difference.
But then we go
back to our height,
which is our length scale.
And we say it's 2.7 meters, just
as sort of a standard ceiling
height.
If you plug in the properties
of air with these numbers,
the Rayleigh number is
actually 10 to the 10.
It's enormous.
So that tells you that if you--
and that's partly because of
the huge scale here, right?
So H comes in cubed.
So if you have 2 or 3 meters of
height, that's a lot of height.
And so if you are maintaining
that kind of temperature
difference across
such a height, you're
going to be generating
very serious convection
in that system.
So what's happening is that
besides the fact that you're
blowing and generating
flows by inertia,
you also have these
thermal flows going on,
which can be very,
very strong in a system
when there's even just a
few degrees of temperature
difference.
You've probably
seen dust in the air
near a sunny
window, which allows
you to visualize the flow.
And even if nobody's
moving-- the air
is fairly still--
you might see plumes
of rising air in one location
or sinking in another air.
And if you look
closely, those plumes
may actually have very complex
convective instabilities
and turbulence even, even when
the temperature differences are
not so great.
And in fact, we can
see such things.
For example, if we have,
let's say, a window--
and let's say that
it's cold outside.
And it's warm inside.
Then just simply that
temperature gradient
means that there's a colder
air near the surface that
wants to sink.
And so the flow rate
is going to look--
or the flow is going to look
something like a boundary layer
flow of fluid that is sort
of falling near the surface.
And if the Reynolds
number gets high enough,
this flow can actually
become itself unstable
as it kind of goes
down the surface.
So you can see that
these rising or falling
plumes of natural convection
near vertical services
that are heated or cooled
relative to the environment
can also lead to complex flows.
And actually, a
good example of that
is the flow that
occurs around a person
just simply due to
the temperature.
So if you look very
closely at a person--
I'm not going to draw
it very well here.
But let's just say,
we have a person.
And that's supposed
to be a head, OK?
If you look very
closely, the body
has a temperature
which is usually higher
than the ambient by at least
10 degrees if not more.
And if you now plug in a little
bit smaller size-- let's say,
we plug in 30 or 40 centimeters.
And we-- so let's
do that actually.
So if we say that here, maybe,
H would be on the order of--
well, since this was 3 meters,
we'll go down to 0.3 meters.
So we'll drop the size
roughly by a factor of 10.
But it comes in cubed .
So that drops the Rayleigh
number by a factor of 1,000.
So if we still keep our
delta T at 10 degrees--
and it might actually
be much more than that--
the Rayleigh number
around this person's head,
just simply by virtue of the
heat generated by the body,
can be of order 10 to the 7.
So it may not be quite
into the turbulent regime.
But it's certainly in
the regime where there'll
be some unsteady
complicated flows due only
to natural convection.
And we're not even talking
about the person moving,
which gives you even more flow.
And so what it actually looks
like if you look closely--
the air around a
person is actually
rising almost like a chimney,
driven by these thermal flows.
And those flows even can go
turbulent or at least generate
some vortical structures.
And of course,
these kinds of flows
are just due to temperature.
In all these cases
due to the HVAC
and also due to
the person, there
are these convective
flows that we've
talked about from inertia,
which also contribute to mixing.
So as we'll talk
about shortly, we also
know that this
person is breathing.
Let's say, they're just
breathing through the nose,
even.
Then there's some puffs
that are generated.
And you've got the
thermal stuff going on.
Also, the air that
you're breathing out
is warmer than the ambient.
So it tends to want
to rise as well.
So I hope I've convinced
you here that--
I'll write this as, these could
be buoyant respiratory jets
and puffs.
So I guess the first
part of this section
is just to convince you that
the conditions in a room
are such that we
have good reason
to believe that there is
significant mixing of the air,
either due to inertial
effects from movement,
from ventilation air flows,
or from thermal effects,
as we have sketched here.
And so at least, that
gives us a beginning
of a justification
for our assumption
of a well-mixed room.
So in this video from Linden's
group at the University
of Cambridge, we can see a
visualization of the airflow
around a person who is
speaking or just breathing.
And the videos are taken
by a differential synthetic
schlieren imaging
method, which allows
you to see basically the
changes in density in the flow.
And what we see are
these thermal plumes
of warm air rising past the
body due to the difference
in the body temperature and
the ambient air temperature.
And we also see, on top
of that, repeated puffs
coming from the breathing,
which interact with those plumes
and also themselves have buoyant
and turbulent flows therein.
In the next video, we see
how different the flows
are when masks are worn.
So we can still see the thermal
body plume rising vertically
past the person's face.
But now the mask is preventing
the transfer of momentum
to the fluid to push
forward these puffs.
And instead, we see
the leaking of some
of the breathed, exhaled
air rising, almost
entrained in the turbulent
thermal plume rising upwards
rather than being
ejected forward.
And so this helps to eliminate
short-range transmission
due to those puffs and
really brings us closer
to an airborne model
of a well-mixed room.